things that fit inside the galaxy note 3
display part 1.
[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the galaxy note 3 from samsung this
phone is really new it's really quite
nice so far and it's really big uh this
is a huge phone and it's not the biggest
phone out there obviously but we kind of
had to see this coming i mean the first
galaxy note was a runaway success and it
had a screen size of 5.3 inches and then
the galaxy note 2 came out a year after
that and it has screen size of 5.5
inches and here we have the galaxy note
3 and the screen is 5.7 inches diagonal
now i have big hands so sometimes it's
kind of hard for me to show how large or
small devices are relative to other
things and i mean you know this phone is
big but it's kind of hard to show
exactly how big it is so that is exactly
what this video is for i'm going to be
comparing it to some other relatively
similar size smartphones and some other
household objects to hopefully give you
a better idea of exactly how big the
galaxy note 3 is now no this is not the
full review obviously this is just a
size comparison but that is definitely
coming up soon so be sure to subscribe
below if you haven't already to be among
the first to see that when it comes out
it'll be a very in-depth video but
without any further ado let's go ahead
and check this out so the easiest way to
get the point across is with the exact
dimensions of the note 3. so if you have
a ruler get it out handy this device is
5.95 inches tall by 3.12 inches wide and
0.33 inches thick that's 151 millimeters
in height and 71 millimeters wide and
the thickness is 8.3 millimeters so it's
actually a little bit narrower than the
galaxy note 2 was by a little bit as you
can see they really took the design of
the galaxy s4 here but you might not
have a galaxy note 2 or a galaxy s4 but
here's something a bit more familiar
this is the iphone 5s and all its
fingerprint sensor glory
this iphone has a four inch display
diagonally so i'll move that over the
side here now there's another phone that
comes in a similar size body but with a
slightly larger display and that's this
moto x and that comes with a 4.7 inch
display and you can see how similarly
size they actually are when you put them
next to each other but a lot of people
don't get to do that but either way
moving right on up here we have a five
inch display in the form of a galaxy s4
and you can see we're starting to get a
little bit bigger here to the point
where you think that's a significantly
larger device than the iphone and then
we get to another even larger device the
oppo find 5 that also has a 5 inch
display but when you put it alongside
the galaxy s4 you can see it looks even
bigger and you're starting to push the
limits of your pockets here and of
course then we bring in the galaxy note
3. this is our 5.7 inch display and you
can see it actually doesn't look all
that much bigger than the oppo fine 5
despite having a much much larger
display but at the end of the day when
you zoom out a little bit and take a
look at the smallest of the tablets it's
still nowhere near the size of the nexus
7 and it's significantly more pocketable
so the bottom line here is the galaxy
note 3
it's big it's not ridiculously big it's
not too big for most people like some
other devices that i have shown on this
channel before and some more that i have
in the pipeline obviously but it's nice
to know exactly how big it is relative
some other things on a scale now there
are some devices that i wasn't able to
show you guys because i don't have them
but i'm going to point you guys to a
link right below that like button to
phone arena's site and they have a tool
at that link where you can actually
basically calibrate your display to the
phone you have and hold it up to the
display and get a real-time comparison
of what other similarly sized
smartphones look like so it's really
useful tool so if you have a smartphone
that i didn't show or if you just have a
smartphone and want to see the exact
representation of the note 3 size
relative to your phone you can do that
at this tool so i'm going to point you
to that that's the link below that like
button either way this has been it thank
you for watching if you enjoy it feel
free to give a thumbs up and without any
further ado i'll sign off and get to
work and get to testing got some testing
to do
peace
[Music]
you